I'd be interested to ask you a question
why are you a Democrat I got it you
become a Democrat I can tell you why I'm
a Republican even though I don't even
fit in the Republican Party anymore I'm
a Republican because the union's my dad
was in a union here on Long Island
forty-one years as a blue-collar crane
operator hourly worker and anybody
that's lived out here in Nassau County
knows that the unions were controlled by
the Republican Party so when I was a kid
growing up my dad was a staunch
Republican for those reasons and he was
like you know what you're a Republican
and oh by the way you're turning 18 yeah
that's great you're registering as a
Republican I said okay if that's helpful
to you dad then that's what I'm gonna be
that's how I became a Republican how did
you become a Democrat well certainly not
anything like what you just described
you as my parents weren't political at
all my parents immigrated here and
pretty much ignored domestic politics
for me no I remember being excited about
Clinton's election in 92 and I aligned
with Democrats on social issues around
choice and other things and so it just
became very natural and of course like
you mean I grew up in the New York area
at least my part of New York I felt like
was democratic-leaning
but you're you represent a type of
business owner mentality that I also
really embrace and resemble because I've
run a small private company and when
you're in that context it's all just
about the facts it's like you can't talk
yourself into anything you know I think
you know if you decide to run again I
don't know where your long-term plans
are but there's a wave coming and it
will be a post-partisan wave